public sénat avec le soutien du magazine
l'express vous présente
camus l'icône de la révolte
stockholm 10 décembre 1957
dans quelques minutes devant la famille
royale de suède sera remis le prix nobel
de littérature l'assemblée attend le
lauréat un des plus jeunes de l'histoire
il n'a que 44 ans
il s'appelle albert camus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour commencement il y à un gosse ébloui
par la méditerranée
l'été sans fin
[Musique]
quel chemin pour cet exilé ce petit
français d'algérie
né dans un quartier misérable dans une
famille qui ne sait ni lire ni écrire
ce jour-là il pense à sa maman qui n'a
jamais quitté l'algérie
à stockholm sa femme francine est à ses
côtés elle qui a si souvent était dans
l'ombre d'autres femmes
maman nous a dit et vous savez avec
votre père je regrette rien
ce que ça n'a jamais été médiocre
derrière le smoking se cache un homme
qui déteste les mondanités les
interviews et n'est jamais aussi heureux
que sur un stade de foot
[Musique]
un homme généreux mais déterminés qui ne
renonce jamais un instant de bonheur ne
dit pas comme ça sans penser à mal
ingénument je suis heureux camus est un
des auteurs français les plus lus dans
le monde chaque génération se
l'approprient du groupe rock the cube à
patti smith des auteurs de bd au street
artist il est branché il est comme il
est de son temps il m peel et de
maintenant et ça c'est fabuleux
c'est quelqu'un qui vous donne le goût
de la vie sans jamais vous mentir
nouveaux ratios camus s'y révolter
contre tous les totalitarismes et
aujourd'hui sa voix porte plus que
jamais
à travers le monde les défenseurs de la
liberté le site en modèle
[Musique]
son histoire commence de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée
à cette époque l'algérie c'est la france
depuis 1830
des centaines de milliers d'immigrés
venant de régions pauvres de france
d'espagne d'italie sont venus sur cette
terre d'afrique s'inventer un avenir
[Musique]
la nuit du 7 novembre 1913
l'orage gronde
c'est dans cette ferme sont sages femmes
ni médecin que le petit albert voit le
jour
sa mère catherine camus est originaire
d'une famille espagnole
son père lucien est ouvrier agricole la
terre est pauvre le paludisme règne huit
mois après la naissance d'albert la
première guerre mondiale éclate
[Musique]
lucien camus traverse pour la première
fois la méditerranée
il part se battre sur une terre froide
est inconnue après deux jours de combats
il prend un éclat d'obus dans la tête
sur son lit d'hôpital il écrit à sa
femme je suis blessé ce n'est rien
ton mari il meurt une semaine plus tard
camus n'oubliera jamais cette leçon de
courage
sans ressources catherine camus
s'installe avec albert et son frère chez
sa mère à alger ils vivent rue de lyon
dans le quartier très populaire de
belcourt
c'est des gens pauvres quoi c'est
l'équivalent d'une cité et bien tout
tout de suite ça match avec un gamin qui
vient de de nos cités aujourd'hui et
cette figure là qui grandit dans un
environnement presque similaire et bien
tout d'un coup on se dit ok c'est l'un
des nôtres
la mère d'albert est femme de ménage
presque sourde elle est aussi douce
qu'effacer c'est une femme qui a
beaucoup souffert mais qui a souffert de
manière digne silencieuse c'est une
femme d'ailleurs qui a été entouré par
le silence et qui en un sens peut-être
se définit par le silence puisque elle
parlait très peu
elle avait l'habitude lorsqu'elle
rentrait du travail de prendre sa chaise
d'aller sur le balcon de sa soirée de et
de contempler l'horizon sans parler
cette relation est très touchante parce
qu'on voit bien tout l'amour que camus
as pour cette mère avec qui il est
difficile de parler à bellecour les
camus vivent sans eau ni électricité
c'est la grand mère qui gère le foyer
d'une main de fer
chaque sou compte
albert n'a qu'une tenue pour la ville
mais elle est toujours impeccable
chez eux il n'y a pas un livre et on ne
parle pas de dieu à la maison la grand
mère dit d'un mort en voilà un qui ne
pétera plus
la vie quotidienne est dure mais il n'y
a jamais chez camus ni ressentiment ni
misérabilisme il écrit seul moi et mes
défauts sommes responsables et non le
monde où je suis né il restera toujours
nostalgique de cette jeunesse un monde
où pour albert les plus grands plaisirs
ne coûte rien
les délices des bains de mer les
sensations du sel du sable sur la peau
albert jouit de l'instant présent
c'est sa force et l l'habitera toute sa
vie camus c'était une force de la nature
c'était un boule d'énergie il adoré
courir marcher se promener se baigner
autre plaisir gratuit
les parties de foot avec les copains
quand on joue que l'on soit fils de
femme de ménage de notaire tous les
enfants sont égaux oui j'étais gaulle au
racing universitaire algérois qui
portait d'ailleurs les couleurs du
racing club de paris
le goal du racing la période à son
excellente forme il faut pas l'accabler
séquence dans l'étau milieu des bois
qu'on s'aperçoit que ce déficit camus
est le gardien et être est il est
concrètement gardien de but mais dans
son approche des choses c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui protège qui protège et qui
est gardien de valeurs gardien d'une
vision du monde
finalement gardien d'humanité fr je n'ai
connu que dans les sports d'équipé au
temps de ma jeunesse
cette puissante sensation d'espoir et
d'exaltation qui accompagnent les
longues journées d'entraînement jusqu'au
jour du match
victorieuse ou gueule
le peu de morale que je sais j'en ai
appris sur les scènes de théâtre et dans
les stades de football qui resteront mes
vrais d'université l'école de la
république peut changer une vie
lorsqu'il entre en primaire le petit
albert n'a aucune instruction
c'est là qu'il rencontre un instituteur
exceptionnel louis germain
l'homme à qui il devra tout ce
professeur décèle chez albert des dons
une sensibilité unique
monsieur germain c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui a ouvert camus à la littérature et
au monde et il a très vite remarquer que
albert n'était pas un enfant comme les
autres qu'il avait une curiosité une
intelligence une finesse d'esprit qui
était assez exceptionnel pour son âge il
se rend compte que cet enfant est
particulier et il faut en faire quelque
chose on peut pas laisser ça comme ça et
donc il pousse cet enfant une valve
chercher fait enfant le jeune camus
poussé par monsieur germain est en tête
de classe à la remise des prix
moustiques comme le surnomme son
instituteur à cause de sa petite taille
est le premier à monter sur l'estrade sa
maman mémé d'alger n'est pas peu fier et
mémé d'ailleurs j'ai toujours la tête
albert il ya la tête
albert est un excellent élève
pourtant pour sa grand mère pas question
qu'ils poursuivent des études
secondaires
il a l'âge de ramener un petit salaire
mais pour monsieur germain
il doit tenter le concours de boursiers
l'instituteur vient deux fois rues de
lyon il insiste et finit par convaincre
la grand-mère camus obtient la bourse et
entre au lycée bugeaud d'alger le
premier jour
albert comme ses camarades doit remplir
une fiche pour profession de la mer il
écrit ménagères son voisin le reprends
ta mère travaille chez les autres elle
est domestique pas ménagères je pense
qu'on essayait pas beaucoup peut-être
pas tant que sales d'enfants de femmes
de ménage et donc il a dû sentir
il dit j'ai eu honte et j'ai eu honte
d'avoir honte
camus est influencé par jean grenier son
professeur de philosophie avec qui il
entretiendra une longue amitié
écrivain grenier l'initié aux grands
penseurs nietzsche qui apprend à vivre
sans dieu
nietzsche dont camus gardera toute sa
vie cette photo il se plonge aussi dans
kafka shakespeare
dostoïevski les stoïciens grecque
très jeune il sent qu'il porte une
oeuvre en lui
albert dévore la vie mais un jour en
plein match de foot il s'écroule il
crache du sang c'est la tuberculose
camus il n'a pas pris conscience de la
mortalité en lisant un texte
existentialiste en lisant kierkegaard il
a pris conscience de la mortalité en la
regardant en face en se disant je suis
en train de mourir là je crache du sang
potentiellement je peux mourir son
poumon droit est gravement atteint à
l'époque c'est une condamnation à mort
il quitte à alger pour un séjour au
sanatorium il fait que tout ça peut
s'arrêter quand il a conscience très tôt
que tout ça peut s'arrêter il veut vivre
et il vit
malgré la maladie il obtient son diplôme
universitaire de philosophie mais en
1935 à cause de la tuberculose
il doit renoncer au concours de
l'agrégation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
camus est beau garçon et il le sait il
s'habille en dandy à la bo gars ou un
rebelle à la genting camus a du style
camus et steen et c'était un donjon il
passe ses week-ends sur les plages aux
alentours d'alger se gorgent de mer et
de soleil
les filles sont belles albert fait le
beau il est drôle physique fait chavirer
les coeurs
elle s'appelle christiane even simone il
dit pourquoi faudrait-il et mais
rarement pour aimer beaucoup camus on
brasse tout amour littérature mais
engagement politique aussi révoltée par
les inégalités
il veut agir dans ce milieu des années
trente le bouillonnement de l'histoire
est intense
en russie les communistes promettent le
bonheur pour tous une société sans
classes sur les conseils de jean grenier
camus s'engage au parti communiste
algérien en 1935
sa motivation est clair soutenir les
opprimés algérien
[Musique]
avec ses camarades il fonde une troupe
de théâtre écrit une pièce sur une
révolte ouvrière en espagne il soutient
les républicains contre la dictature de
franco
il dira c'est en espagne que ma
génération a appris que l'on peut avoir
raison et être vaincus ils se méfient
déjà des appareils politiques n'est pas
dupe de la propagande rouge et il
comprend vite que moscou se fiche des
conditions de vie des algériens
camou n'a pu rester dans c'est dans
cette atmosphère irrespirable qu'une
année c'est à dire il n'a pu vivre dans
un lieu où on essayait de penser à sa
place que pendant que pendant une année
l'engagement communiste de camus est une
façon d'être vacciné contre le
communisme mais je crois que le vaccin
était déjà inoculé
en 1937 il quitte le parti communiste
sa conscience politique s'affûte sa
plume aussi il publie l'envers et
l'endroit en 1937 une déclaration
d'amour pudique à sa mère il dira
pardonne ton fils d'avoir fui le silence
de ta vérité
il écrit aussi plusieurs nouvelles noces
l'été une ode à cette lumière qui
répondent les richesses de la simplicité
j'attends j'attends longtemps parfois je
trébuche je perds la main la réussite me
fuit qu'importe je suis seul alors je me
réveille ainsi dans la nuit et à demi
endormi je crois entendre un bruit de
vagues la respiration des eaux
réveillé tout à fait je reconnais le
vent dans les feuillages
je n'ai pas trop de tout mon art pour
cacher ma détresse ou l'habit hier à la
mode
albert écrit mais il doit gagner sa vie
son ami l'écrivain pascal pia qui dirige
le quotidien alger républicain langage
comme journaliste
camuzat y défendre un journalisme qui
offre une voix à ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
une série d'articles va marquer
l'histoire de la presse en juin 1939 il
par plusieurs semaines en immersion dans
la région de kabylie
ils dénoncent l'exploitation coloniale
et réclament le droit de vote pour tous
c'est une description assez clinique de
la situation des kabyles à savoir
l'absence d'écoles absence d'hôpitaux
les enfants et les parents qui meurent
de faim il écrit j'ai vu à tizi ouzou
des enfants locke disputé à des chiens
le contenu d'une poubelle l'isère en
kabylie montre bien que s'il ya bien un
occidental soucieux des douleurs qui lui
sont épargnés série s est même le
premier à en parler mais laventure
d'alger républicain tourner court
interdit le journal est rebaptisé le
soir républicain camus publié un article
sur la liberté de la presse
il est censuré à la veille de la guerre
il n'a plus ni travail ni avenir en
algérie
1939 les bruits de bottes résonne
partout dans le monde
en italie le duce chauffe à blanc les
fous le japon occupe la chine hitler
lance son offensive surprise sur la
pologne dans ce vacarme tragique
commence une période incertaine pour
camus il n'est pas mobilisables à cause
de sa tuberculose il part en france
rejoindre pascal pia au journal paris
soir puis il revient en algérie en 1941
c'est à cette époque que camus épouse
francine fort
francine qu'il a connu à oran avant la
guerre
elle est professeur musicienne à oran
son salaire fixe albert vichy ses beaux
parents
le moral n'est pas bon il a 27 ans et se
vit comme un raté mais un livre va
subitement le projeter dans la lumière
l'étranger
ces premières lignes deviendront cultes
aujourd'hui maman est morte ou peut être
fière je ne sais pas j'ai reçu un
télégramme de l'asile mère décédée
enterrement demain sentiments distingués
cela ne veut rien dire c'était peut-être
fière l'étranger c'est l'histoire d'un
homme simple morceau il travaille fait
l'amour se baignent mais parle peu ne se
plie pas aux codes sociaux il ne pleure
pas le jour de l'enterrement de sa mère
morceau c'est quelqu'un qui ne jouent
pas le jeu
dans un monde où tout le monde ment ban
lui dit la vérité il est tout temps il
dit tout en la vérité et ce qu'il
ressent il le dit et d'une certaine
manière pour moi morceau c'est le
symbole absolu de l'honnêteté
pour moi meursault est atteint de ce que
j'appellerais la folie de la sincérité
ce qui distingue ce personnage c'est
qu'il ne veut jamais dire plus qu'il ne
s' en
[Musique]
plus tard dans le roman meursault tue un
arabe sur la plage sans raison ni
regrets à son procès les jurés le
condamne à mort davantage pour son
apparente indifférence que pour le crime
lui-même les jurés se rassurent le
diabolisant c'est une scène qui décrit à
la perfection la manière dont on a un
besoin maladif de francs de fabriquer
des monstres mais dans un monde
justement qui est un nombre de juges
un monde où il faut qu'il y ait les
coupables et les innocents forcément il
n'y a pas de place pour quelqu'un qui
porte ce regard là sur le monde
[Musique]
camus envoie le manuscrit de l'étranger
aux éditions gallimard à paris pascal
pia et d'andré malraux en font l'éloge
emballé gallimard le publie en 1942
[Musique]
l'étranger deviendra l'un des romans les
plus lus en france et à l'étranger
camus ses morceaux un rebelle épris de
vérité
à partir des années 60 les marginaux les
libertaires et les rockers vont
s'identifier à lui
il a inspiré un titre decure patti smith
lui a dédié une chanson elle dit quand
je veux être meilleur
je pense à camus camus s'affiche sur les
murs on le tag on le dessine on se
gravent sur la peau il est devenu une
figure iconique et c'est dans le paris
des années 40 que le pied-noir exilés a
commencé à sortir de l'ombre
depuis 1943 camus électeurs chez
gallimard à paris ton épouse francine le
rejoint un an plus tard il est très
proche de michel gallimard avec qui sur
ces images il fait le pitre
cette prestigieuse maison d'édition va
devenir sa seconde famille
en zone occupée
les français vivent sous le joug
allemand
certains collaborent d'autres font le
dos rond mais une petite minorité
s'organiser résiste camus en fait partie
il rejoint le journal clandestin combat
un journal qui appelle à la résistance
contre l'occupant y travailler c'est
risquer sa vie
il y retrouve pascal pia pour tromper
l'ennemi
il apparaît sous plusieurs identités
camus que l'on voit ici re lire des
articles m ce travail d équipe
les bouclages nocturne avec les
typographes les imprimeurs cette
camaraderie
finalement entre les hommes cette
camaraderie là c'est hyper important
parce qu' il s' est lui plus que les
autres on n'existe qu'un individu il
n'existe pas seul comme ça que c'est la
connexion avec d'autres qu'on fait
partie d'un tout c'est lui qui dit
solitaire mais solidaire
cela s'appelle la camaraderie je crois
qui a été une des grandes joies de ma
vie très vite il s'impose comme
rédacteur en chef il dénonce la barbarie
allemande en partant de faits concrets
comme dans cet article
pendant trois heures ils ont fusillé des
français
[Musique]
il y décrit en détail
l'exécution de 86 prisonnier par les
nazis
les corps trous et les visages éclaté
il publie aussi durant la guerre quatre
lettres à un ami allemand imaginaire il
lui explique que les nazis vont perdre
la guerre parce qu'ils sont aveuglés par
la haine
cabu n'est pas pour autant pacifiste si
la violence est toujours inacceptable
elle est parfois inévitable
c'est un texte où camus annonce à son
interlocuteur qu'il va le tuer si
nécessaire puisqu'il est en guerre
contre lui et en même temps qu'ils
refusent de déshumaniser ils
débarrassent la guerre de la haine c'est
un homme sans haine qui parle à son ami
allemand la vie nous oblige la vie nous
oblige à aller coûte la vie nous
obligent au dialogue
la vie nous obligent au partage etc etc
les mains tendues entre deux
belligérants sont rares dans notre
histoire récente lettre à un ami
allemand est un appel à la
réconciliation au dialogue entre les
peuples et les individus
voyez aller texte de camus sur la
violence en fait parfois on a
l'impression qu'il a écrit sur notre
époque
lorsqu'il traite de la difficulté que
l'on a à dialoguer parfois on a
l'impression qu'il a connu les réseaux
sociaux moi je me souviens de ce texte
où il explique le mécanisme de la
polémique il dit qu elle consiste à
simplifier à s'impliquer l'adversaire et
par conséquent a refusé de le voir et où
il ajoute celui que j'insulte je ne
connais plus la couleur de son regard on
a l'impression qu'ils parlent de twitter
à la libération de paris
combat sort de la clandestinité camions
restent le rédacteur en chef il est
l'une des plumes les plus aiguisées de 7
après guerre un des articles restera
dans les annales nous sommes le 6 août
les américains largue une bombe atomique
sur la ville d'hiroshima
elle fera deux cent quarante mille morts
camus est un des rares à anticiper la
menace de l'apocalypse nucléaire
à l'époque la grande majorité ne voit
dans hiroshima qu'un point final au
conflit mondial
ces hommes nés au début de la première
guerre mondiale
qui ont eu 20 ans au moment où
s'installait à la fois le pouvoir
hitlérien et les premiers procès
révolutionnaire
qui furent confrontés ensuite pour
parfaire leur éducation dans la guerre
d'espagne à la deuxième guerre mondiale
à l'univers concentrationnaire à
l'europe de la torture et des prisons
doivent aujourd'hui élever leur fils et
leur oeuvre
dans un monde menacé de destruction
nucléaire
après la libération albert et francine
décide de rester à paris
l'étranger est un succès plus question
de retourner à oran en 1945 naissent
deux jumeaux gens et catherine
[Musique]
les camus sont fauchés mais cet après
guerre et joyeux saint germain des prés
à l'époque c'est le lieu où les
intellectuels les artistes la jeunesse
refont le monde
on boit on danse on écoute du jazz
bref on revit
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
dans les caves du quartier latin
camus est copain avec sartre beauvoir et
tout le clan gallimard il déjeune une
fois par semaine avec sartre le pape de
l'existentialisme qui vient de publier
l'être et le néant
les deux écrivains s'admire camus a
publié un article élogieux sur la nausée
sartre lui écrit plus de 20 pages sur
l'étranger
camus admire l'incroyable machine
intellectuelle de sartre mais l'homme
aussi papa 10 est toujours celle savent
qu'ils soient généreux face et seule
parade à imiter la main au portefeuille
pour payer les pots el papa et 7 et 2
ils étaient tous ronds comme des
quotes-parts faut bien dire papa est
pareil tu partirais citron est
complètement mort ait traversé le pont
il s'arrêter sous la tour eiffel
évidemment on va regarder sa culotte
camus est un rigolard tous ceux qui
l'ont connue dans l'intimité raconte
qu'il plaisantait sans cesse le bonheur
après tout est une activité originale
aujourd'hui est la preuve est qu'on a
tendance à se cacher pour l'exercer à y
voir une sorte de ballet rouge donc il
faut s'excuser
les gens qui l'ont côtoyé le sable
c'était un bon pote on rigolait bien
avec câble
l'époque est à la déconnade un matin
camus arrive au bureau avec un coquard
sous ses lunettes
la veille le grand écrivain arthur
kessler passablement imbibé a voulu
casser la gueule au philosophe merleau
ponty
mais c'est albert qui s'est pris le
poing dans la figure
une autre fois à la terrasse du flore
camus voix sartre qui barrent at il
longuement une fille il lui demande
mais pourquoi tu te donne tant de mal
sartre lui répond tu as vu moi la gueule
que j'ai centre admis réclamer pour deux
choses d'abord camus avait une meilleure
descente que lui elle tenait mieux
l'alcool et et puis il avait plus de
succès ou plus exactement il n'avait pas
besoin de déployer
on sort de génie vertigineux pour avoir
du succès sartre il est en mode
gainsbourg albert est naturel non
séduisant et il soigne son look son
fameux style à la bogart ses amis le
savent quand une jolie femme passe
camus n'est plus avec eux et les flirts
s'enchaînent
mais une femme va rester la comédienne
espagnole maria casarès camus la
surnommera l'unique maria rencontré au
théâtre durant la guerre
[Musique]
quand il ne se voit pas ils s'écrivent
plusieurs lettres par jour
il ya une lettre de marjah où elle lui
dit mais ils sont pas vus depuis trois
quatre jours ce qui pourrait être une
éternité et elle dit mais je vais
m'allonger je vais plus bouger jusqu'à
ce que tu reviennes elle me dit mais
sauras tu me réveillais sauras tu être
mon prince charmant
c'est très familier à les marier c'est
vraiment son âme soeur camus ne cache
pas cette relation à francine et bien
sûr les crises
les scènes sont nombreuses albert essaye
de ménager sa femme sont cédés sur ses
désirs
c'est un grand vivant qui assument
toutes les petites passion qui peuvent
aussi être les siennes sa grandeur et la
sai thein win
c'est un homme normal c'est à dire qu'il
était aussi capable d' égoïsme
c'est pas un saint c'est pas un saint
c'est plus fort que ça c'est un vivant
un vivant pétri de paradoxes de
contradictions il peut être indifférent
lointain orgueilleux et ne s'en est
jamais caché papa savez ce qu'irene si
on faisait trop chier d'accord il faut
être hautain dans la société
intellectuelle
je ne sais pourquoi j'ai toujours
l'impression d'être coupable il me
semble toujours que je viens
d'enfreindre une des règles du clan cela
m'enlève du naturel bien sûr et privés
de naturel je m'ennuie moi même façon ex
enfant ce qu'il avait
la mère qui avait la pauvreté qui la
trame allait quand même les années de
guerre qui ont étaient terrifiantes pour
lui
bah il allait à l'essentiel à lui et
dans les soirées mondaines
c'est tout sauf l'essentiel l'essentiel
c'est mal élevé
camus se sont souvent plus proche des
milieux anarchistes il deviendra une
égérie libertaire un modèle de
contestation
[Musique]
le parti communiste jouit d'un immense
prestige le système stalinien étend son
emprise à l'europe de l'est à cuba et
beaucoup d'intellectuels le soutiennent
sartre en tête
camus lui est lucide il consacre
plusieurs textes aux dangers d'une
violence aveugle au service d'un idéal
incertain
le premier est la pièce les justes qu'il
met en scène en 1949
c'est l'histoire de révolutionnaire qui
sont écartelés doivent-ils lancé une
bombe pour tuer un tyran au risque de
sacrifier ses enfants qui l'accompagnent
est ce que parce qu'on vit une injustice
alors on est légitime et à commettre un
meurtre ou un assassin de l'assassinât
c'est toute cette réflexion et c'est
important
donc c'est important la révolution mais
pas n'importe quelle révolution et pas à
n'importe quel prix
je veux vous parler franchement et vous
dire au moins ceci que pourrait dire le
plus simple de nos paysans tuer des
enfants est contraire à l'honneur
et si un jour moi vivant la révolution
devait se séparer de l'honneur je m'en
détourne le ray
[Musique]
cette question posée dans les justes
résonne aujourd'hui elle renvoie aux
attentats qui tuent des innocents comme
au nigeria
il ya eu il ya deux trois ans à une
tentative d'attentât
l'attentât de boko haram il ya une des
trois femmes qui reconnaissant un enfant
qui était le sien dans le camp a refusé
de faire exploser sa ceinture
on est exactement dans un modèle cannes
vient exactement et tout l'espoir du
monde est là
en 1951 camus poursuit cette réflexion
en publiant l'homme révolté
dans cet essai il vise la gauche
marxiste qui idéalisent la révolution
qui justifie les camps au nom d'un
avenir radieux
il oppose à sartre les principes d'une
gauche réformiste non communiste il ya
cette espèce de fantasme romantique au
temps de la révolution qui fait que
beaucoup d'intellectuels se sont
aveugles et là où camus qui pensent non
pas par par grands principes ou de
manière abstraite mais qu'ils pensent de
manière concrète au corps à ce que ça
veut dire 20 millions de personnes dans
les camps lui n'a jamais eu cette
illusion c'est une des grandes leçons
camus rien n'est plus confortable qu'une
pensée radicale une pensée extrême il
n'y a pas plus bourgeois que
l'extrémiste parce qu'il est bien à
l'abri derrière le confort d'un écrit en
1 ou en deux mots de ses propres
opinions mais dénonçait les dérives
révolutionnaire ne veut pas dire
renoncer à l'action
camus dit oui à la révolte
quand elle dénonce une injustice une
oppression sans chercher à détruire
comme la résistance pacifique de gandhi
en inde
[Musique]
ou la marche pour les droits civiques de
martin luther king aux états unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas une révolte qui nous séparent
de l'autre c'est une révolte qui nous
dit j'ai jeu j'ai besoin de l'autre je
suis avec l'autre nous sommes ensemble
il faut bien comprendre cette révolte la
révolte n'est pas révolution la révolte
selon camus n'est pas un règlement de
comptes mais un projet un combat
incertain sans fin pour la justice et
les libertés ce fut le cas en chine en
1989 à tiananmen en 2011 en tunisie
le printemps arabe
en 2019 à hong kong on a vu des
manifestants brandir la formule
camusienne je me révolte donc nous
sommes
en 1952 la publication de l'homme
révolté a provoqué une polémique
mémorable sartre directeur de la revue
les temps modernes considère cet essai
comme de la morale pour boy scout il
demande à son collaborateur le
philosophe francis jeanson de porter le
fer l'homme révolté écrit jenson c'est
d'abord un grand livre manquer camus
ulcéré répond mais directement à ça
[Musique]
monsieur le directeur on ne décide pas
de la vérité d'une pensée selon qu'elle
est à droite ou à gauche
si la vérité me paraissait à droite qui
serait je commence à être fatigué de
recevoir centraide leur leçon
d'efficacité de censeur qui n'ont jamais
placer leur fauteuil que dans le sens de
l'histoire
[Musique]
sartre réplique
dites moi à camus
et si votre livre témoigne et simplement
de votre incompétence philosophique
je n'ose vous recommander de liens
l'être et le néant la lecture vous en
paraître et inutilement ardue
les deux amis ne se reparleront plus
j'étais vers les coraux diamants joseph
a pas triste
il m'a regardé et m'a dit je suis seul
j'ai même pu dire ouais et th en seule
la brutalité des attaques blesse camus
il fuit paris dès qu'il le peut
direction la lumière du sud de la france
où il retrouve son ami son frère rené
char
rené char 1 mètre 90 joueurs de rugby
lukas d'aînés se casse un doigt
c'est un résistant de la première heure
camus le considère comme le plus grand
poète contemporain
il a édité chez gallimard
il aime cette force de la nature
ancré dans son village du luberon qui ne
fait aucun compromis
char mesure le sentiment d'exclusion de
camus mais il le rassure
face aux critiques parisienne il avait
ni non mais albert séné suppositoire et
qu'est ce que ça fait suppositoire sa
faune
char en a vu d'autres il a mené des
opérations contre les nazis
il sait ce que ça fait que de se
retrouver avec un homme décapité devant
les yeux que de commander sa mise à mort
et c'est justement parce qu'il sait ça
qu'il a trouvé que l'homme révolté était
un texte magnifique si camus est isolé
en france
il est reconnu à l'étranger par les plus
grandes figures démocratique
les dissidents soljenitsyne pasternak
miloche tous les trois prix nobel de
littérature et la philosophe hannah
arendt qui a analysé les origines du
totalitarisme
hannah arendt elle est criminelle de
catherine jacques amyot 11 ans je vous
rencontrer
j'aime votre homme révolté elle a
demandé à rencontrer camus et elle dit
mais parmi tout le lot sartre et les
autres il n'y a qu'un seul qui vaut la
peine c'est camus lui il a tout compris
à partir de 1954 une autre tragédie va
déchirer l'auteur de l'étranger
un cycle infernal se met en place entre
français et nationalistes algériens des
répressions féroces répondent aux
attentats aveugles des indépendantistes
du fln les deux camps rivalisent
d'atrocités
une partie de la gauche avec sartre
milite activement pour la décolonisation
la droite elle veut que l'algérie reste
française
camus le pied noir est écartelé il dit
j'ai mal à l'algérie comme j'ai mal aux
poumons
il est totalement prise avec ce pays
voit bien tous les dysfonctionnements et
les a décrits suffisamment et en même
temps il se résout pas ce que ce pays
puisse être abandonné par une partie de
sa population et qu'on dise à un million
de personnes vous n'êtes pas chez vous
c'est même pas rentrer chez vous s'est
séparé de la cua dégagé dégagé de là
donc ça évidemment ça ne se peut pas
vous marchez pas ça peut pas fonctionner
camus se bat pour une réconciliation
entre les deux communautés
il prône un système qui donnerait plus
de droits aux populations arabes mais il
ne peut envisager l'idée d'indépendance
pure et simple
seulement camus lui ne veut pas
l'accepter ils ne l'acceptent pas
effectivement c'est une ses mains pas
une question politique et n'accepte pas
c'est charnel pour lui il ya vraiment
quelque chose de complètement
complètement irrationnel à ce moment-là
chicane pour comprendre la position de
camus sur l'algérie c'est lui a dû se
dire mais expliqué à ma mère quand fait
un jour elle va devoir partir parce
qu'elle est pas chez elle c'est quelque
chose qui de l'ordre de l'inconcevable
mais je pense qu'il ya quand même une
erreur politique c'est de considérer que
les choses peuvent être encore à ranger
alors qu'il est trop tard elle aurait pu
être arrangé dans les années 30
peut être au début des années 40 mais en
54 55
il est trop tard déjà horrifié par les
milliers de morts d'innocents sacrifier
de part et d'autre il publie plusieurs
articles dans l'express en janvier 1956
il ans à alger un appel à la trêve
civile
il écrit chaque mort c'est par un peu
plus les deux populations
demain elle ne s'affronteront plus de
part et d'autre d'un fossé mais au
dessus d'une fosse commune
mais en défendant une approche nuancée
il passe pour traître à droite comme à
gauche il a tenu et il continue à tenir
la position la plus difficile
quelle est la position du juste milieu
l'incapacité camusienne à émir un quant
aux dépens d'un autre devrait nous
servir de guide pour comprendre ce qui
se passe dans le conflit israélo
palestinien c'est à dire si chaque fois
qu'il ya une catastrophe là bas les
représentants des différentes
communautés prenait la parole pour
défendre l'argumentaire de la communauté
d'en face alors il y à d'excellents
arguments des deux côtés pour défendre
l'argumentaire de la communauté d'en
face pédagogiquement on ferait des
progrès formidables
camus isolés menacés voit que
politiquement son message ne porte pas à
partir de ce moment il va se taire et
c'est dans cette période de souffrance
que l'écrivain accède à une gloire
inattendue
[Musique]
en octobre 1957 il apprend qu'il vient
de recevoir le prix nobel de littérature
sur le coup il répète en boucle c'est
malraux qui aurait dû la voir cet
hommage le flat bien sûr mais l'écrasent
aussi
alors qu'ils se sont jeunes encore riche
des livres à venir
ce prix l'an terre vivant [__]
angoisse ce que ça pue un mois ci
quelques jours après l'annonce il rédige
un mot à monsieur germain
son instituteur d'alger votre travail
est le coeur généreux que vous y mettiez
sont toujours vivants chez un de vos
petits écoliers qui malgré l'âge n'a pas
cessé d'être votre reconnaissante élèves
je vous embrasse de toutes mes forces
mais ce qui est beau dans le courrier
qu'il écrit à monsieur à monsieur
germain c'est l'humilité c'est à dire ça
reste monsieur germain
ça reste son enseignant s'il n'ya pas
monsieur germain
on n'a pas ce prix nobel on n'a pas ce
grand on n'a pas cette grande figure
intellectuelle
à l'époque il fréquente la comédienne
catherine c'est leers
mais c'est à sa femme francine qu'il
propose de l'accompagner en suède
recevoir son prix il dira elle a
toujours été là dans les moments
difficiles je lui dois cela seul génie
tsin dira plus tard que camus a prononcé
à stockholm le plus beau discours du
nobel
un discours qui n'a pas pris une ride
chaque génération sans doute se croit
voué à refaire le membre la mienne sait
pourtant qu'elle ne leur fera pas mais
sa tâche peut être plus grande
elle consiste à empêcher que le monde se
défasse
[Musique]
dans les jours qui suivent un scandale
éclate
camus est accusé de n'avoir pas dit un
mot sur les algériens il répond en ce
moment on lance des bombes dans les
tramways d'alger
ma mère peut se trouver dans un de ces
tramways
si c'est cela votre justice je préfère
ma mère certains journalistes trompe
cette phrase et lui font dire entre la
justice et ma mère je préfère ma mère ce
qui bien sûr n'a rien à voir
cette fausse citation le fait passer
pour un différend au sort du peuple
algérien alors que toute sa vie démontre
linverse
[Musique]
tragédie algérienne polémique camus a du
mal à se remettre
[Musique]
il n'arrive plus à écrire le calme
il va le retrouver en grèce avec maria
casarès et les gallimard
avec l'argent du prix nobel
il achète une petite maison en provence
à lourmarin à côté de chez rené char
dans ce sud qui lui rappelle les terres
algériennes
il se lève tous les matins à l'aube pour
marcher dans la nature
il reprend un texte qu'il porte en lui
depuis des années le premier homme le
premier homme c'est lui lui qui a dû se
construire seul sans mémoire familiale
samper fin 1959 camus passent noël en
famille à lourmarin avant de remonter à
paris il écrit trois lettres la première
à mettez y verse une étudiante danoise
pour laquelle il a eu un coup de foudre
je t'attends plein de force et de
passion m'a bien aimé ma jeune fille mon
amante chéri la deuxième il écrit à
catherine c'est leers à mardi ma chérie
je t'embrasse déjà été bénie du fond du
coeur
la troisième lettre à maria casarès
je n'ai donc plus de raison de me priver
de ton rire ou de nos soirées ni de ma
patrie je t'embrasse
je te sers contre moi jusqu'à mardi où
je recommencerai après le réveillon il
dépose sa famille dans un train pour
paris puis il prend la route avec son
ami michel gallimard
il roule vite le 4 janvier 1960 à 13h55
sur une ligne droite la voiture s'écrase
contre un arbre albert camus est tué sur
le coup
dans les débris on retrouvera sa sacoche
à l'intérieur les feuillets d'un roman
inachevé
le premier homme
il se termine par ces mots mourir sans
révolte
ce manuscrit est dédiée à sa mère à toi
qui ne pourra jamais lire ce livre
bon
quand on annonce la mort de son fils à
sa maman elle ne pleure pas elle dit
juste c'est trop jeune
recevoir et donner n'est ce pas après
tout le bonheur la vie innocente dont je
parlais au commencement mais oui c'est
la vie elle-même forte libre dont nous
avons tous besoin
allons donc nous occuper du prochain
spectacle
[Musique]
public sénat avec le soutien du magazine
l'express vous a présenté cas mais
l'icône de la révolte